stocktonianic approach is an alternative
to the string theory which solves
quantum gravity or potentially does the
octonians are non-associative
eight-dimensional extension of the real
numbers complex numbers and quaternions
the multiplication of octonians is
non-commutative and non-associative
however they exhibit exceptional
algebraic and geometric symmetries that
make them a fascinating and useful tool
in various areas of mathematics and
physics Arnold Summerfield used the
octonians to describe the symmetries of
the hydrogen atom later Jeffrey Chu used
the octonia to develop a theory of
Elementary particles based on the idea
of a nuclear democracy in which all
particles are on quote unquote equal
footing more recently the octonials have
been used in string theory and M Theory
where they appear in the context of
exceptional structures that describe the
Dynamics of supergravity the octonians
have proven to be a powerful
mathematical tool with surprising and
revolutionary applications in physics it
could well be that a non-commutative
geometry based on the octonians is the
successor of the pseudo-ramanian
geometry of Einstein's general
relativity